today I want stick to football we're
chilling at the BR gridiron House at
1111 Lincoln Road Mel O'Connor myself
Matt we have a live audience there's a
DJ it's gonna be a little crazy today
swing set there's a swing set they're
handing out Taco Bell it's in that Pat
mahomes shirts I should have worn mine I
got one yeah I don't I don't think what
do you want to let that fly but we're
excited to be here excited to have an
awesome show
obviously we finally got the name right
1111 Lincoln we've been calling it 1 1 1
1 1 11 a hell of a lot better than there
are seven ones in this address try to
find yeah then you have to try to think
did I say three or five I don't know but
there are a lot of ones this show comes
out Monday morning mellow or myself will
probably be hungover on South Beach
somebody come find me bury me dig me out
of the sand because this show comes out
after the Super Bowl but in true stick
to football fashion we're gonna let that
stop us from doing what we normally do a
blind review is gonna happen we're gonna
talk to our guy Kenny Vaccaro former
Texas Safety Tennessee Titans more
importantly important ladies
former Texas safe to use that one but
now a Titan safety was with the New
Orleans Saints we've talked to him about
trying to stop this Chiefs offense what
it's like to tackle Derek Henry which
cannot be fun and then guys we have a
lot to talk about as far as the the
quarterbacks in this class because
there's been a lot of news coming out
this week and that's where I want to
start the show today because we have
your Dan here on a radio row doing media
and all the prospects come through Joe
Burrell was on with our guy left co2 has
been doing social stuff fall down at be
our gridiron good over the place almost
all of them almost all of them and I
don't even think it's fun talking about
Joe borough anymore it's like he's
penciled into the number one pick with
Cincinnati that's locked in it's done we
know he's a good player I think
everything shifts right now to what's
gonna happen with to a ton of Eylau it
well I think we would borough I think
the one thing we do have to talk about
he comes out this week and says he wants
go number one but he wants to go to a
team committed to winning Super Bowls
and Joe is very media savvy he knows
every word that comes out of his mouth
what that means I think it's interesting
because Carson Palmer in Miami this week
said that he felt like the Bengals were
never committed to winning a Super Bowl
they're using the same verbage so I
don't want to start the conspiracy
theory that Joe burros gonna spawn Eli
and say I'm not going to Cincinnati
we've talked to Jim naggy about the
actions there with Zack Taylor the head
coach Cincinnati played with Joe burrows
older brothers at Nebraska hell of a lot
of dots to connect between these two
teams but I do think it's interesting at
least that burl would say yeah I want to
be the first overall pick but I would
rather go smart where they're committed
to when there's a veteran of the booth
here today you were covering the draft
for Eli was 21 years old I can't imagine
though trying to go you can have a beer
during that draft I did have a good
draft card right right that's why I get
the big butcher Joe Burrell word to say
I want to go to a different team it
would wreck the whole draft everything
all the work that we put in for the last
almost a year on this kind of room for
change everything would change in that
split second it would and I think
Bengals fans have asked us at least a
couple are wondering what would the
price even be and you're talking
multiple first-round picks for that kind
of no matter where it is you have to
figure the Dolphins would be interested
in making that kind of move there's no
doubt about that thing a lot of teams
would maybe even though the Vegas
Raiders would do something crazy I just
don't think we're ready for that
conversation yet well and it seemed like
the Indianapolis Colts they have won
first-round pick this year they have two
second-round picks this year and a GM
and Chris Ballard who went to
Indianapolis thinking he had his
franchise quarterback and Andrew Luck
and then Andrew up and retires and he's
left with Jacoby bris it who it's been
okay but he's not what we think Joe
Burrell could be so I think it's only
interesting because the verbage that
both quarterbacks used and the obvious
connection there I will say that with
with Joe he knows that that coaching
staff he knows the front office and he
didn't want to be a Cincinnati Bengal we
wouldn't be hearing about it on the Dan
Patrick show or you know on the left go
show we'd be hearing about it it's that
idea Tyler Murray situation last year
when we were at the Super Bowl and
everybody started talking about it is he
coming out or anything like that Joe
burrows got a good head on his shoulders
I think he goes to Cincinnati I don't
think we have any problems with that I
think he just wants to make sure that
the scouting department at the front
office and everybody's committed to the
same goal that he is because we've even
poked fun at the Bengals yeah they don't
employ a lot of scallops they don't
travel to a lot of games and you're
gonna have to
surround him with a good - I'm they have
a reputation of a being a franchise that
let's be real guys it's they can be
cheap at times and I think for borough
there's an aspect of this of listen he's
going home and that means a lot to him
broken about where he's from he's spoken
about the community he's raised money
for that community but I think he also
needs to set the tone right now and put
the pressure on them and say listen you
have the number one pick and I'm excited
to go home but you better better be
ready like LSU was to not just be in it
you need to be ready to spend money to
win football games to get this thing
going in the right direction the second
I step foot on and maybe he's saying hey
with the 33rd pick please draft Justin
Jefferson he's there right you know
build some town around him
Connor you mentioned it though to talk
about Lola continues to it seems like
every time we stop talking about him he
makes news earlier this week he said he
will be at the combine and I think it
was a little confusing the way he worded
it a lot of people ran with it and said
oh he's gonna perform at the combine
that's not what he said he said he
doesn't expect to win the 40 he's not
trying to win the benchpress he wants to
win the medicals we've talked about this
a lot with 2a where the draft
conversation with him starts at number
three overall it could be number three
it could be number six number seven it
could be 12 beat 13 it could be 30 it
could be 30 he could go late in the
draft it all depends on the hip where we
just no one can have an educated opinion
right now about where he's at but he is
right that the medicals the physical
that he has to pass late February when
we get to the Scouting Combine is really
what we're waiting to see with his draft
stock I mean I think we've come
full-circle on to it when you look at
this right now I mean it starts out the
year is the number one overall
quarterback it starts out as projected
number one pick
obviously the injury we talked about hey
maybe he falls out of the first round
maybe he comes back to school now with
all the medical you know updates and
indications it looks like to us worked
his way right back into the top three
again he's obviously not going to
supplant Joe burrow as the number one
pick we don't expect that but I think
the tricky thing with to it is right now
it's no secret that Miami Dolphins love
him and they have for quite some time
now the problem is every single team
knows that and all of those teams behind
them or and the teams in front of them
can start to plot how they're gonna move
up and down this draft board give up
draft capital to go get him or get get
more draft capital to move back down so
I think Miami at five
one of the most interesting spots of
this draft and that's because of tua
assuming those medicals go right at the
combine which I like that he came out
and got in front of it he said listen
before even the physical stuff gets
going he needs to show that he's okay
medically clear to go and it said to his
dad yesterday in an interview said the
Dolphins are the preferred destination
for him so it's funny you go back and
listen to this show in August and we
were like ah tank for tua they're taking
for two of the dolphins were getting
they accidentally won five games and so
they have the number five overall pick
in this draft but on the other side of
that like we've said with the Jets
before the Browns before the Eagles
teams have known okay we're gonna have
to move up to get our quarterback and so
they stockpile draft picks and that is
what the Miami Dolphins have done by
trading Laremy Tunsil by trading Kenny
Stills by getting rid of some of those
contracts and guys that we didn't think
we're gonna be there long term they now
sit at number five overall they sit at
number 18 overall and they also sit at
we come back round number 26 on row says
the team has a ton of picks we're like
the Eagles do when they traded up to get
Carson Wentz they've already set the
table with those draft picks where they
can now go up and get their guy so too
is the guy with Miami Dolphins it's not
a matter of draft capital because they
have 13 picks in this draft so what they
have in the second round is also huge
what they have in next year's draft
where they have two first rounders these
huge so if the Dolphins love to uh they
can go up to three and grab him if the
line I mean if the Lions have any sense
about themselves they're gonna answer
that phone call they purposefully put
themselves in this situation they knew
they needed to rebuild they trade it off
some really good players young players
to to put themselves in the position I
think it's gonna cost two first-round
picks whether it's moving up to three or
even four I think that teams are gonna
say we know you have the picks you're
gonna have to give us something we want
it's probably gonna be two pressure on
pips yeah I think when you look at it
they're probably sitting there hoping
that they could trade 39:56 those two
second rounders they have along with
five to go up to three but I'm with Melo
where a lot of teams are gonna sit there
and they're gonna hold out for at least
that 26th overall pick and trying to
double up on first rounders and if
you're Miami it's an interesting
situation because you've promised this
rebuild for a long time right you have
Chris Greer who finally gets upgraded to
the big boy chairs GM after a lot of
years behind like Tannenbaum there
you've been just completely you know
building out this foundation now are
trying to build out this foundation you
need a quarterback in place you can't go
into next year
which is Ryan Fitzpatrick as the only
guy no and Ryan Fitzpatrick this week
said he expects to be back in Miami so I
think he even knows the deal he's gonna
be a bridge quarterback again which is
really really good at he'll be a bridge
quarterback until he's 65 exactly and
that beard will be majestic and him I
still don't play in yeah five years old
so I think we're starting to see the
draft like the top picks take shape
we know Joe burrow and think Jabbar was
gonna go to war in a row they're really
really good about it we think chase
young is gonna go number two feel good
better about that actually I felt better
about chase young going number two
overall I could do that you know like we
talked about confidence meter like Joe
burrow like ninety nine point nine at
one stage I choose 100% and then at
three if there's not a trade up then
Detroit looks at someone like Jeff
makuta but if two is off the board the
top five we think he will be the
Panthers at seven the Chargers six
Panthers at seven a lot of teams right
after that need a quarterback guys and
we were just in Mobile Alabama some of
us haven't even been home since we were
in Mobile Alabama some of us have yeah
lucky guys here we saw Justin Herbert
have I think one of the better weeks
I've ever seen a quarterback have there
and I would say you know Baker Mayfield
had a good week Josh out had a good week
carson wentz had a good week their dak
Prescott Derek Carr I think you put
Justin Herbert in the conversation of
one of better weeks that I've seen in
ten years ago into the Senior Bowl it I
think he showed that he can make those
in FL throws he's not just a guy that's
gonna sit there and run the RPO Oregon
watching him throw the ball from the
hash to the sidelines is what I wanted
to see a mobile and we did and I think a
lot of teams fell in love with him
especially the team sitting at number
six and number seven the Chargers we
know they're moving on from Phillip
Rivers
the Panthers I don't really know what
they're doing yet but I know that
looking at that position you're drafting
number seven you don't want to be that
high again you probably want to go get
your quarterback did you see the article
cam said this week he's gonna be back
it's what they say
Odell said he wasn't in trade left sure
that's a good point well the great thing
for the Panthers is they don't have to
rush here I mean you have Matt rule
there who's on what six-year deal you
have Joe Brady there now who's a 30-30
year-old offensive coordinator so when
you look at it for them they don't have
to rush but talking about Justin Herbert
we love what he did last week in Mobile
and there's no doubt he solidified
himself as a top ten pick but it goes
back to something you said Matt when did
we get to see him go to the second and
third reads because you don't get to see
that and practice
often with Herbert I still think in a
one read offense which does exist now
we've seen it with Sean McVeigh a lot
with Jared Goff there's a lot of times
where guys are schemed to open and
Herbert can flourish in that he can move
very well he can run he obviously has a
really strong arm but he needs to land
in the right spot and I think it's
really come down to the Chargers and
Panthers for him in those spots but I'm
still curious to watch the Vegas Raiders
and the Colts and this and maybe even
the Bucks they're sitting on the back
end watching at 12 13 and 14 do they do
something aggressive to go up how much
longer is Bruce Arians gonna be coaching
maybe he wants to go get a guy now Jon
Gruden we'll see what the relationship
is with Derek are we last year yeah we
thought they wanted one last year we
seen all right quickly he sours on guys
and the Colts it's no secret they're
gonna be looking at quarterbacks
no I definitely don't think the Coulter
secret so ideal landing spot for me
Justin Harbor is La I think the scheme
fit is good but also get a team over to
a stadium you need some tickets and you
need to do that with the hopes and
dreams of a rookie quarterback
especially one who's well known on the
west coast so sometimes like aw doesn't
business doesn't need to factor into
this no they need to sell tickets they
couldn't get 22,000 people to go to a
soccer stadium they're gonna have to
sell some tickets
I think Justin Herbert hope to do I
think they almost need a complete
rebranding and I think that starts on
the football field with the quarterback
I agree with you I think Justin Herbert
we can probably pencil him in mock
drafts get really screwed up because one
trade will ruin it all but right now I
think a safe bet would be Justin Herbert
to the Chargers and as we wrap up our
first segment here live from the BR grid
iron house guys there are a couple other
quarterbacks and it seems like everyone
basically agrees in the top three and
then all hell breaks loose because you
have Jordan Love who is like what do you
do with the guys were 17 picks and 2019
what do you do with Jacob Eason who we
really have like two seasons of film but
there was the year and a half or the
year off didn't have a ton of town
around about Washington really seemed to
struggle against good defenses and then
you have Jake from who did nothing at
Georgia really the last two years but
three years ago I'm firing off tweets
about Jake from looks like a future QB
one so I think there are a lot of
questions about these guys that's how I
stacked them Jordan love Jacob Eason
Jake from and I'll say with Jordan
Lovett Jacob Eason they can be top 15
picks and I would not be surprised and
those are risky top 15 hello risky as my
children would say I mean they really
feel like they're on the Josh Allen
spectrum of risky and I know Alan the
Bills had a really real
season we're seeing him develop but once
again there's a reason when you're that
out of control with the football that
like Eason and love specifically have
been the counter with Fromm is the
opposite he's not a guy that takes
chances I think he's a guy that manages
the game really well you can't use a
first round pick on a guy like that
though that's a long term all right spot
starter kind of guy I mean I think the
best version you get out of Jake Fromm
in the future is Kirk Cousins but I
don't think he's on Kirk Cousins level
well I would put a like Kirk Cousins
Andy Dalton yeah guy that you take
probably in the second round at the
beginning of the the second round maybe
let him develop a little bit for a year
or two behind somebody and then he can
come in and start taking reps I don't
think he's ready to immediately but
there are a lot of teams drafting on
that second round the Colts maybe the
Colts go somewhere else in the first
round then on the swing they'll draft a
guy like Jake from or storing behind
were set for a year you're listening to
this Monday morning the people who are
here with us at our live audience I have
a seven round mock draft coming up
Monday morning because I have no life
and apparently don't like my girlfriend
I haven't go to the Vikings in the
second round perfect fit go play in the
dome Kirk Cousins has one year left on
his deal and you're the same quarter
like I think they're I think the mirror
images of each other would Jake from the
one thing that could eventually bite us
and we could get cold ticked on this his
talent level also dropped off this year
and I know wheat is gorgeou the year I
have two offensive tackles drafted you
have to Audrey Swift the receiver talent
really dropped off Isaac Nauta goes to
the draft so you lose some talent in
production at the tight end position
Jake from you're never gonna look at him
he could walk in this room right now and
no one would know who he is we can you
might be here he was he was here the
other day I mean hopefully he's not
around yet if he is cool Jake but you
know he's not that big physically
imposing quarterback where you're like
oh my god like I remember meeting Cam
Newton and being like that's that's
quarterback like that's 65 to 45 so what
did ask him for a picture
I just wanted Jake from yeah Georgia
fans travel well we know that we know
that from tailgate tour Georgia fans
really you mentioned though that if we
could get burned here and get put on
cold takes I also think you could for
saying that he's not gonna be good no I
think that we could look back at Jake
from in a couple years and say man he
was getting it done in SEC look at the
schools that he's done it against and
that offense has not really been
quarterback center he turns around and
he hands the ball off a lot yeah this
year there was no talent out receiver
freshman came in at
that job and pickings it's gonna be a
good receiver but it also wouldn't
surprise me if a guy like from really
was a good solid starter in the NFL for
a long time I think he'd be Alex helmet
for a Wolves exact which I've had a
really really good career before he got
hurt I think that's a great point though
Melo something that we don't do enough
even on the show but definitely draft me
and he doesn't do enough how do you
analyze guy in an offense that is not
LSU yeah what are you asking him to do
exactly I mean there wasn't a Jamar
Jason and I know they have really good
skill players especially when they're
not throwing punches but once exactly
while you're on the field they're not
suspended right so when it comes down to
it you do need to take a look at it from
from and said listen he wasn't asked to
do a whole lot yeah and that's why the
quarterback evaluation I always say it
starts in January because you can watch
guys on the fill you watch the film
we've seen I think we've seen Joe Burke
play five times in the last two years in
person and so now it's okay now it's
more the tape study what what can you do
which is the essence of what can you do
not what didn't you do or can't you do
let's take a break guys we come back
right Kenny Vaccaro on the show we've
got some hats to get mellow Chuck some
hats these people throw some hats out
there one has to give away Taco Bell
being giving away hit the Niners fans
over there no Melo it's about as
accurate as my homes it's gonna be
tomorrow night so it only places loved
apparently I did the same thing I don't
know why I'll get the Niners fans here
we go look at that Jimmy G style
accuracy over here I will be back when
it is we are back here stick to football
taking over the BR gridiron House 1111
Lincoln Road I'm gonna keep saying that
address even though people can't get
here I've been told for two weeks say
they dress a dress then I finally
learned how to say it right yeah so
happens happens but we are gonna have
Kenny Vaccaro here shortly there was a
little bit of a mix-up with the address
that might be my fault it was my fault
you put too many ones in the address
again it's been a long two weeks at
least it's on yeah yeah yeah he'll be
here shortly it's my fault
we'll get him from the free hat and make
up for it but one thing we did want to
talk about we've got an amazing live
audience here keep showing up I got more
hats to throw you know these guys can't
hit you but I can we got some hat which
I by far the worst athlete of the three
of us which is funny what we do want to
talk about those free agent quarterback
buzz because
Tom Brady is tweeting cryptic photos
drew brees is maybe gonna retire Taysom
Hill has been anointed the heir apparent
there and he's a restricted free agent
this year something that we have to talk
about Phillip Rivers has moved his
family to Florida now that we're here I
do understand why definitely understand
why you're there in Tampa they're not
Miami yeah there's a big is leaving LA
yeah I don't
what's that actually confirmed because I
know people were speculating it was
Tampa Phil's not going to Miami those
nine kids nothing against Tampa I just
cannot imagine with anyone there we got
to Tampa fans right I shouldn't talk a
lot of [ __ ] about Santa too because
we're gonna be this time next year
that's literally where we'll be right is
that right never from New Jersey all
right some tips for next year I'm where
to be where to hang out let's talk about
where these quarterbacks are gonna be
though Tom Brady let's not pretend like
any of us knows where he's gonna go Adam
Schefter or Jay Glazer we'll break that
news and then we'll we'll react to it or
Brady will on social media that's maybe
more like it does feel different this
time now I want to make that clear it
doesn't feel like the same old you know
they'll just get an extension done and
he'll take the the fact that it's coming
out that he's done with the discounts
then the cryptic photo and the rumors
that he cleaned out his personal suite
at Gillette which could be true could
not be true there's something different
and one thing we're not talking about
here enough guys is maybe it's bill
maybe it's not up to Tom maybe bill is
just like you know what
this ship has ran its course I'm gonna
draft a quarterback or I'm gonna sign a
quarterback that I feel better about
right now he's probably tired of
watching the quarterback he wanted go
win games can you do it
and even we forget they jacobi percent
who I know he's not all worlds but he's
won a lot of football games in the NFL
he's had younger quarterbacks that could
have stepped in in that system
and had success so how much longer is
Bill gonna keep passing on the chance to
groom guy he's not getting any younger
no he's the second oldest coach in the
NFL right and he'll probably coach until
he literally can't afford more but I
think it is interesting there's like
this is well known that they wanted to
keep Jimmy Garoppolo and the word open
to trading Tom Brady
and Robert Kraft stepped in and said no
so we can I actually believe both what
you're saying if man maybe bills just
done that doesn't matter matters if
Robert Kraft has done his old obk is
signing the checks so as long as he
wants Tom Brady he's gonna get Tom Brady
assuming Tom Brady does want to be there
that I could also see Tom Brady just
wanting to mess with everybody and send
all these messages of oh I might be
leaving it's real it's like the first
time they just come he's not doing
anything this week Super Bowl week and
he's like you know how when a be every
Sunday morning you'd be some wild a bee
tweets like well he missed his football
he's gonna get crazy on Twitter maybe
Tom just misses the Super Bowls he's
like I'm gonna stir up [ __ ] I make it on
Instagram and post a photo that you
can't tell which direction I'm walking
so if not Tom what which is one free
agent quarterback that you could see
actually going there that's realistic to
newey or them yeah Jerry Stidham beat to
the punch
i-i've heard they really liked yours to
them enough where you going to the year
and you go Jaret Stidham is our guy
maybe I don't
it's tough because I think what they
would see is we have a quarterback now
in a rookie deal let's just load up
everywhere else because some they've
never really been able to do under the
modern salary cap structure of we have a
quarterback on a rookie deal let's go
get some free agents let's get hunter
Henry let's get AJ Green but yeah I
guess but Tom makes like 15 million on
the cap that's not a lot
I think I do think was did them they
like him enough to feel comfortable that
we haven't seen them at anyone else and
I know it's only been a year so they
couldn't wrap that could definitely
change but there are definitely a lot of
people around the league to think that
Stidham is good enough to be the guy I
think Teddy is the perfect person to go
there I agree with that actually I in
like Phillip Rivers isn't gonna fit in
in New England I don't think he was what
was left I think I got benched
I don't think he has anything left I
think Phillip Rivers like we're just
it's like he's so funny and he's got
nine kids and he wears a bolo tie so
we're like Oh where's Phillip Rivers
gonna go then the Saints have already
pretty much said take some pills the
next guy they're not gonna look at Teddy
Bridgewater so if I'm him I'm at it and
wasn't a Peter King that said Andy
Dalton could be potentially for New
England
that's very believable yeah after we
just went on this rant how Jake Fromm is
her cousin right Andy Dalton and I was
like wow maybe New England and so I also
other places that you really can't rule
out for Tom Brady
at Tampa we got a bucks fan here Tom
Brady in Tampa Bruce Arians like you
said earlier Connor he does have much
time left and you have Mike Evans you
have Chris Godwin that decent line a
very quarterback friendly scheme Roseau
had a nice breakout year about life is
there's a lot there's a lot of options
there and I think Tampa is a spot what
about the clothes do you think he would
go back and like just like take
Manning's house from the wood if there
is something going on in that locker
room between him and Bill I think that
the Colts have to become the favorite I
think that he would be the guy that says
you know what you don't want me here
fine I'll go to Indianapolis I'll try to
win a Super Bowl there where Peyton did
it well I don't think it also says
something about you know playing indoors
right now I think that could mean a lot
to him and I know that Chris Ballard is
well respected around the league where
you trust him to build the roster or
supportively the offensive line that's
something that's gonna matter a lot all
of this just take Quintin Nelson and
have him pick up Tom Brady at the
airport yeah right with his dad you're
not leaving
yes that but we can't forget they do
have one more year no matter what if she
probably percent not saying Jacoby
wouldn't take them back with recently
yeah first decent money enough so and
then one guy we have to talk about today
and I'm sure we're gonna get to ask
Kenny about this is of course Ryan
Tannehill and I do think this one gets
done just to be clear I don't think
Tennessee is gonna open this hole that
quarterback because they're gonna be
obviously picking very late in this
draft where they're not gonna get a guy
for next year I just look at the Ryan
Tannehill situation it feels like
franchise tag or extension and nothing
else
be honest he's 32 years old he just had
the best year of his life as a
quarterback I think one of the tags
makes the most sense whether it's the
the franchise tag or they're getting him
to come back on a conditional tag where
you know oh we have the right to a first
refusal we'll see what happens we're
gonna get a pick if you leave but I
agree like you you can't let him leave
you've been looking for a quarterback
since Steve McNair and you finally have
someone that could get you to the AFC
Championship game whether it was all him
or not he got you to that point I do
worry that the Titans could be another
Jaguars know where it's like you have a
great defense and a quarterback makes in
a probable run to you and you hang on
for a little bit
yeah when you date the crazy brony like
no it's okay it'll get better you're the
veteran without I almost think the
franchise said makes sense for both
sides dude I do because I think number
one it's a lot of money of course two
Ryan Tannehill in one season money that
he will flat and he made a lot of money
in Miami let's not forget that it's a
lot of money but it's also a one year
window where if Ryan Tannehill has
replicates the success of this past year
he can go into next year the negotiating
table and say what I'm 32 years old
give me a Kirk Cousins kind of deal give
me a hundred million dollars most of it
guaranteed for the next three to four
years whatever it may be so I think the
franchise say it really makes sense for
both sides and let's not forget this is
a team that also has to get we'll see I
don't know if they're gonna get it done
but a contract extension done with Derek
Henry and he wants a lot of money
he said well or is the Zeke Elliott deal
or is Louie Killian which of your Derek
Henry you should be here on every single
show saying that you should go get your
money when when you're getting that
getting the ball as many times as Derek
Henry got the ball this year and you're
you know gonna be what 26 years old
they're running back in the NFL you get
one shot to get this kind of contract
you don't know her too you really don't
get hit there we go Steve every day he's
got a cash in on it right now yeah cuz
we you especially you met have been
talking for a long time about how long
is that body gonna hold up one more
contract I'll guarantee that he proved
me wrong on his first one he's got one
more contract any whether it's a
four-year or five-year deal he's got to
cash in on it I wouldn't take the
franchise tag but I asked his don't
think he's gonna get Zeke Elliott money
we've seen running backs tried to test
it Melvin Gordon said he was gonna hold
out I think guess what he came back he's
like you know what no I'm good I need to
make some yeah bailed out and took less
money than he was offered in Richmond no
offense Conner went to a worse team yeah
of course he did and I mean not being
such a running back guy you know running
backs are amazing you need a running
back you got a run to win now I'm like
man I would use you like a rented car
like I will draft you the fourteen over
years five years whatever and you're out
the Niners because the scheme they can
find guys undrafted late rounders your
Chiefs
Damian Williams bring in a guy off the
street and he's there starting running
back
there are too many good athletes who can
play running back to and to pay 120
million dollars a year or whatever he's
expected 24 million that's ridiculous
there's no way I would pay I wouldn't
pay any running back in the NFL that
money you just can't do it because the
chance of injury obviously the amount of
capita Cup and replicating the
production so easy we do it every day
I'm every week on mock draft Monday I
know Matt you like this big if you're
the Titans you can actually you can't
really get a quarterback replacement at
the end of the first round but you can
and I love Derek Henry and I hate to say
it but you can get a Derek Henry
replacement at the end of the first
round and you could take your pick of
which one you like JK Dobbins Jonathan
Taylor I mean the list really goes on
and on between those guys flood Edwards
elaire I mean if you want to go around
to you go fly that it would still air
you have to Andres Swift is he gonna
sneak into the first round or is he
gonna be a second round guy but the
point is you can find running backs all
the time and it just makes it so hard
for me to tie up that amount of cap
space into one and we will ask Kenny
about this don't forget the right tackle
Jack Conklin they rolled the dice
thinking that he had some injuries play
dropped off they rolled the dice on him
didn't pick up his fifth year option now
he's gonna become a free agent he's
going to get paid very well in the open
market so that affects the quarterbacks
as well because how much money did the
Titans have you can't it's like Dallas
you can't pay everyone yeah that's gonna
be and the Cowboys another team that's
getting to a spot that it's almost
impossible to keep everybody happy
with that money Teddy Bridgewater you
guys said New England is good for him
for him I think
Indy's a good fit for Teddy I don't say
the charters are a good fit for Teddy
dude I don't want him healthy you would
do the rowing do you think Indy would
bring in a guy like Teddy Bridgewater
when you already have reset the Tampa
fans are like please we want Teddy you
know I know you're never supposed to do
this my everybody all dressed in crab he
can't throw deep and Bruce Arians you
kind of throw deep Teddy just can't do
it so I mean I know Teddy is like the
he's the build a ball right now everyone
wants Teddy Bridgewater because you went
five and L looks really good I loved him
coming out the draft everyone I'm sure
remembers that Oh Teddy was my guy and I
think warm climate for him is the best
possible situation well we also forget I
mean Teddy is 27 years old he turned 27
in November so and I know it's a little
different looking at his age because you
go while the injury concerns are still
obviously there
the fact is if you believe that he can
stay healthy you can actually build
around him for the next couple of years
instead of a lot of these like rivers
and Brady feel like these one it's only
your hand a Fiat guys that you're just
praying have another year left in the
tank for them where I don't I don't feel
like that would Teddy well the two guys
then that I want to ask you about Jameis
Winston and Marcus Mariota you started
young guys and we've seen some
quarterbacks just get out of you know
Ryan Tannehill is one you get every a
fresh start and you go to another team
you have some success
Carson Palmer was one of those guys who
just kind of you know got stagnant in
Cincinnati goes to the Raiders and it
doesn't work great but then he goes to
Arizona and he's playing in Super Bowls
so I think when you look at Jameis
Winston who obviously thirty and thirty
this year not great not where you want
to be great baseball great yeah yeah
what Barry Bonds or King Griffey do it a
little different you do a football it's
just embarrassing Marcus Mariota
obviously benched this year for Ryan
Tannehill a guy who just was so
conservative with the football it almost
paralyzed the offense I don't personally
see any situation where those two guys
go somewhere in their clear-cut starter
and I knew Jameis is probably gonna want
starter money Chicago has to add someone
and they both would be such a good fit
for Chicago even though they're very
different quarterbacks having the chance
to work with Matt naggy I think would be
very intriguing to those guys yeah and
like you said they do have to bring
somebody in
Mariota might be like a sneaky favorite
for the Patriots I could see him going
in there and working very well but I
don't see either one of those guys
getting starter money or probably not
just like a clear-cut starter position I
think it'll be a lot more like what we
saw with Tannehill where he comes in on
a one-year pruvit deal and then maybe
somebody falls in love with one of those
guys anything like him I think Mario
does future is probably a career backup
knowing he just didn't impress Jameis
they threw 30 touchdowns somebody might
like that Nelson through the 30
interceptions I wouldn't pay him
somebody might it might be Bruce Arians
I mean where do you even begin to
structure that deal with Jameis yes I
think you say we'll give you 20 million
dollars and you give us a million back
for every interception you throw yeah
well then you play for me do that that's
what I'm doing Thank You million well he
was twenty five million dollars negative
incentive give us a million dollars why
can't you do that you should be able to
do that and then you make money at the
end of the year right it's like people
that buy sole manager
guys because what you just proposed it's
not legal it's GBA like no you actually
cannot do that our guy Kenny's almost
here traffic is crazy I love everything
about Miami
but the Tri Super Bowl week Super Bowl
week you expect it I think New Orleans
traffic was the worst I've ever seen for
a Super Bowl week Philly I one day I
walked a mile and a half which anyone
who knows me knows I don't do that and
it was like it was faster to walk about
and a half then to sit in a car for like
two hours so I don't know how people do
it just sweat through everything but
it's all right yeah like like Melo if
you're watching the YouTube we're just
you're wiping Melo to talk about a
spleen and if you talk about it he's
gonna have here's the one thing Melo
asked was please don't talk about it
during the show it'll make it worse and
not just happy and forgiving that a lot
of people sweat in different ways mine
all comes from my head yeah I have no
back sweat and nothing below the belt
often everywhere as I'm sitting here
guys it's Saturday afternoon where the
BR gridiron House a story is kind of
percolating around Twitter that the
Titans met with Joe in love at the
Senior Bowl not just like a scout but
the GM John Robinson did before we go to
break wouldn't that be crazy is like you
just got beat by Patrick mahomes so you
go draft the junior version of him I
mean isn't that kind of what you do
though that is exactly what you do I I
wouldn't I'm not involved hi Herbert
Orlov I would rather roll the dice on
the second round if I'm the Titans on
Jake from or even I would you bring back
to Hannah Hill at that point yes I I
really I'm not impressed I know they
both had a very good Senior Bowl week
but for me that comes from the bar was
so low coming in for them that it's like
okay you guys can't actually throw the
ball pretty well then those mental
mistakes from both of them taking
chances throwing into double coverage
not getting two reads how is that gonna
get better when the game gets faster
it's not it's not at all and that's
gonna be a problem and I think that was
a Carson Wentz concern it's like oh that
triggers a little slow that's not gonna
get better with everyone being faster
that's exactly it just feels like a
little bit of an overreaction I think
when you look at it just because you
know you want the guy that beats you
let's let's be real like Pat mahomes are
just they're not gonna grow on trees
every year in the Senate draft then you
know a mellow and I have gone into the
and I know Matt you felt the same - is
Jordan love that you know you watch the
2018 film and it's good I think the
numbers might inflate it a little bit
you expect even more I just think he's
got at least a year away and do we think
he's gonna sit there and fall to the
Titans quick because I don't so they're
mortgaging more pics to go up and get
him that would be a really that's that's
a really good point though Connor
because we don't like him that much but
somebody's going to and it's gonna be
somebody in the top ten whether it's the
cold sort of the box or somebody if I'm
the Titans I'm not moving up after I
just that's a big jump and you might
have to reply you might have to replace
some spots
I mean after good seasons guys are gonna
get paid and guys are gonna leave Derek
Henry is the number one Oakland yeah
yeah just it the okay Ryan is also for
agent on defense they needed another
edge rusher they probably get younger on
the D line again after drafting Jeffrey
Simmons so how about we just talk to a
Tennessee Titan about what the type you
should do take a break when we come back
Tennessee Titans safety and former Texas
Longhorn Kenny Vaccaro is gonna sit down
with stick to football guys we are back
with Tennessee Titans safety Kenny
Vaccaro and maybe more importantly to
middle and I former Texas Longhorns
safety Kenny Vaccaro
poco buddy thanks for it was a hell
getting you here because I gave you the
wrong address to my bed after this we're
gonna let Kenny tackle me
no baby I want to see it so please let's
make it happen
this is my guy though he's been
supporting me since I says I got the
league so it's been don't obviously the
Texas man so yeah it's been smooth
having this guy my son so I have to
bring it to you I am a Chiefs fan yeah
here give us some keys what were you
guys looking for on how to stop a Kansas
City Chiefs well it starts a patch of
our homes obviously and I think the main
thing that the 49ers need to do harvest
seeds get pressure if you don't get
pressure on them to me honestly he's our
best player Lee like just playing
against them and like you blitz him he
can backpedal twenty yards and still
throw it thirty so he's throwing 50
yards for a 30 yard pass he's you say
when you're in his own
read the eyes of the quarterback he
doesn't know looks he it's just he make
a man he makes it he makes the engine go
you had to stop Lamar Jackson and then
patch
my home yeah how was Pat different than
Lemar huh I think see what Lamar it was
you know they had their system they did
a great job with building around him and
when they called the play they run the
play Pat can change the protection
change the play honestly like that's
what that's about that was the main
difference that all right if I'm playing
dime backer all right two fours coming
you know let's slide the line to him and
then we'll you know so he knew how to
like prevent the team for being in bad
situations and then obviously his arm
and his accuracy there just know there's
nobody like him like I mean people say
Aaron Rodgers have the same you know
talent but for me when you can make
every throw on the run backpedaling
under duress I mean can't stop it
what do you do yeah you get pressure at
least doesn't like that though so it
felt like for you guys this year is you
kept winning and winning people were
like all like that the Titans like where
did this come down but it probably feel
like that to you right it did yeah why
do you think people overlook you guys so
much think it's because of the
quarterback instability or mellitus
I think it's anytime you're two and four
and you make a quarterback change right
it's that's a rebuilding year we're
gonna see where the Titans go right I
mean everybody just wrote us off
immediately like as soon as they pull my
blue markers you know who handled the
situation phenomenally it's like alright
let's write the Titans off then all of a
sudden you know we go seven and ten the
next team next ten games and now we're
sitting the AFC champion gets Chiefs and
nobody thought we're gonna beat the the
Ravens I mean it was that was a
landslide right the spread was like over
1400 guarantee I mean a lot of people
lost money in Vegas yeah yeah we were
actually mellow an hour at the game
there's a championship game how do you
stay warm when it is that cold
I wasn't that cold it was weird I was oh
my the whole week leading out on my man
we're gonna play in five degrees or
whoever was with the windchill I was so
worried but it was not
I think Kansas City has the heated field
yeah they do so the Stewart was not cold
yeah and then I had a scuba-diving like
cutoff on so my body what my whole body
was warm I wore like the ski mask thing
how was it that's what I'm doing next uh
next you're tailgating at Arrowhead get
the ski yeah you just have to talk to
the players and figure out what they do
and then we'll bring it I mean when
you're playing to your body so hot the
drilling is going I mean you're in you
know you're in Kansas City when the best
stadiums in the league I mean nobody
gets [ __ ] about a Cobra I drank half a
gallon of moonshine to try to keep
myself warm I don't remember if it rang
out we got a moonshine last night Melo
has a present for you though yeah we're
giving out free shirts and everything I
thought you were not gonna respect my
boy oh good Kenny obviously we heard so
much about Dre Ville and you know that
there's kids here but the cuttin off I
saw English yeah all right uh-huh
how is he the craziest coach you've ever
had in a good way I just think he's one
of the guys I don't think it's crazy I
just think he's authentic I'll hit him
the other night he was like yeah I'm off
the grid tonight but I'll link up
tomorrow like just relay it's just the
fact that we're texting you're texting
your head coach yeah he's he's so he's
just he really is that you hear players
coach all the time but there's he really
is one no like there's a not everybody's
like that you know he's I think he's
here doing events and you know he has
friends I mean you know he has former
players that are still playing in the
league you know so he's uh he's a
special special coach how different see
from back Brown here you played under
the night day I mean age difference all
right uh I mean it's different it's
different eras you know this is
different Mack Brown was more you know
to me of like a father figure I lost my
dad when I was 15 so like when I got the
Texas that was the first time I had
somebody kind of over me you know kind
of guiding me as a male figure so uh
Mack Brown was kind of that he didn't
really he didn't positional goes like
brave will have like the pad on he'll be
doing like hand
me you'll have me striking him back
Brown was kind of you know oversaw like
his whole staff how important was it
that relationship with Grable that
brought you to Tennessee I mean I didn't
have one before I got to Tennessee so I
kind of took a chance right I mean he
was your news coach he was the new coach
it was a crazy situation because I was
gonna probably you know that year with
the safety market was crazy I was
confused right and I was actually
pregnant sound like the Jets on just
something like whatever like if I'm
gonna play football regardless and then
you know Jonathan's different eras ACL
and then I end up signing with Tennessee
and the rest is history
and then you get a four-year extension
after that which is nice yeah I think it
was really honestly like this might be
cliche to say but like God's timing I
had to wait one more year you know to
like figure out exactly I was gonna be
cuz I mean how do you you don't go from
you know playing ball like I did like in
the playoffs this year to why I'm not on
the team what you're good you know I'm
saying like yeah I'll the same player
then so that's all I want to ask you
were so productive in New Orleans
obviously first-round pick and then
you're waiting and then same guy in
Tennessee and they're like oh now we'll
give him a four year I don't understand
extension I don't know the market just
doesn't make sense you know I had the
best agent in the world David we'll get
her yeah I said what's wrong he said
every every team says it's just wow we
don't know why it's crazy I don't it
doesn't matter to them I'm here talking
drinking beer like I don't really get I
don't really care I'm just saying how
does that how does that even happen you
know in their FL do you think I'm even
siren tires had a 1 / 7 more Burnett
signed a I don't even know I don't even
know he's you know I the whole market
was just completely gone and all of a
sudden the next year everybody gets bit
damn near max deals is here before that
Tony Jefferson got paid I remember
looking at it because my comp that was
uh actually told my agent like that's my
so going into that free agency I was
like Tony's my boy I love them love them
even though he went to you and I was
like listen I want whatever Tony guy was
wet too
[ __ ] better but I mean it all worked
out you know I'm really not tripping I
mean thank God I was you know I was a
first rompe I wouldn't I wouldn't like
all they are I need to get a new deal
like I had been blessed already but um
it's crazy how it works out so you freak
your quarterback is gonna be in a
similar role this year I mean Greg Ryan
Tannehill took that one-year deal with
Tennessee do you think I mean brain
wouldn't want me to talk about anybody's
contract but you know Ryan did a great
job I mean why would you want to break
up what we did I don't want to comment
on anybody else's situation
it's business man you never know what's
gonna happen I mean Derek's a free agent
to you know he was a big part of what we
did and I mean everybody's asking the
same question like how much they gonna
get paid when are they gonna get signed
I I don't know I just I know we made a
run and the group of guys that I was
playing with you know we all came
together you know and did what a lot of
people think we couldn't do so whether
it's now it's on John Robinson if he
wants to split that up how hard is it to
tackle Derek Henry I thought I warned
you I was gonna ask you this I saw him
out there every game I Terry both his
ACLs have we ever played against some
guys trying to stay up go high I'm like
brides arms or twice the length of mine
he's 250 I mean I'm out so you've
probably had a pretty good view of the
Patriots players it looked like they
were ducking out of the way they wanted
no part of tackling what was the
conversation in the locker I mean yeah
it's you know it's week seven week 18 of
the season and it's cold and rainy yeah
and every every hit hurts a little more
when you're talking on senator 50-pound
bag that runs a full four yeah it's I
have never seen anyone like him which is
why I missed so badly on him it's like
there's no one like this you know
there's Eddie George wasn't even that
big you know if you go back to that he's
been he's big Eddie talks to us he's big
we swish we talk to him this week we
were like and he said send me you know
why would you break that up why would
you break up this team that they just
got together and had this amazing run
exactly and I just think you know
sometimes people overthink overthinking
well we need a guy that can do this or
this no I just just let us be us let let
us be the underdog every game you know
come out do what we did and and that's
fine yeah I just I think a lot of times
people overthink the whole situation
like high teens built like Alomar
everybody was hating on Lamar so after
it's Ricky he'll never do this again who
was the dude who was the person that
said Bill Polian exactly yeah anyways
and I'm sure I'm sure you weren't like
did you have in the morning you're bored
no it's fine but people you don't
understand like certain teams certainly
you know bringing guys together it's
it's different in football that's why I
put ball is the best sport it's the only
sport they you got to bring fifty three
guys together to accomplish the same
goal someone we were really high on was
Jeffrey Simmons coming out of the draft
what was it like when he got back
healthy being a guy in the back end but
having someone up front like that
wreaking havoc first of all he's an
athletic freak obviously since eight
much removed from surgery at d-tackle
he's playing football
that's all I shouldn't have said
anything else yeah he's 300 you know 15
pounds doing that off of ACL addy tackle
I told him the day I saw mich I'd say if
you start playing with like he's so
strong he just stand he don't have to
play pad level he's so strong that I say
you start playing pad bill nobody ever
block you and maybe they won't next year
pads down and stop just grab people like
this he's a big monster man before we
let you get out of here attend oh you
got some things you got to do you're
fine I'm joy talking right now you might
let me go right I don't have anyone ask
you about non football stuff we know
you're busy with twitch I would say you
do you like to wear ears which is like
you're busier on Twitter senior on
football or 17 I just started put on see
like here's the story so in college I
didn't play no video games period I
played when I was younger I stopped in
college I was partying way too much my
fiance's over there ship I say I broke
my ankle my rookie year which I think
changed the course of my career but
we'll talk about that later anyways I
had a spiral break and I was like man
what I'm going to do I just I was
sitting there and I just picked up my I
bought another Playstation and let me
playing it I mean next thing you know
now I'm on you know streaming I'm
partnered with twitch already
honestly like I know people laugh about
it but eSports is the feat is there's so
much money and if the feature of our
world
have y'all seen ready player
you might see that movie yeah it's gotta
be our future I'm telling you know
people can escape from the reality that
they're in and play a game and be
somebody that they never thought they
could be I'm telling you I'll tell you
that's just a few people people want to
escape from reality whether it's you
know whether it's watching me scream
whether it's doing drugs whether it's
playing a video game I like the American
dream is to escape from what you're like
what you're really living yeah which
whether that's bad or not I don't know I
just like that's the future so what's
the game of choice for you I play
destiny and that's the only thing and a
lot of people don't play it like let
people stop playing it
I never switched a fortnight I never
went to you know I don't play mat I
don't play support games I missed so
much time into football I'm not gonna
come home and play Madden yeah you was
all right man you're pregnant lower my
rating I got hurt I was 88 at one point
I got hurt and they just I ain't played
his sentence anyways but I just I played
that was the part I picked up just the
game it just came out destiny I was an
island plate is it was posed to be the
next Halo you remember halo but okay
everybody played it now I'm like boys
with the you know the guy that runs it I
go I'm going out the Bungie in two weeks
I mean this is what I do how much time
do you spend in Nashville which Melo and
I go every year we do a little spring
break and getting back to Texas where
you're from where you're we went to
college how much time not spent in
Nashville yeah just the season just the
season like I'm ready back in Austin
you know rack rack Pope came on the
every other day he invested in a whole
eSports like building he's gonna have
like 70 computers he's doing I mean you
know Jamaal Charles lives down the
street for me you'll love it yeah yeah
how much time do you spend on the 40
acres though because I do feel like none
would you please go back and do
something else talking to Brittany Jones
the other day he was asking about
coverage isn't no I definitely hang out
with the guys in stem I just I don't
know I mean I I need to go back to
school I need to finish it yeah I didn't
finish I like I think 12 hours left of
electives I got to pick what I want I
don't know is they go back this year but
we can't win is yeah what'd you major in
physical culture and sports okay
[ __ ] I want to go into film
but I was smart in high school like I
had a high GPA I was in you know AP
Calculus all that but once I made a
decision to plate like it's hard to do
both like hats off to the guys that you
know they're you know they're pre-med
and they playful it's hard they tell you
can't do it I want to be an architect
when I first got to Texas like you're
not gonna be architects you can't do it
you know I got 6 a.m. workouts and I'm
in my 8 a.m. class just like yeah I
would come flick too much I was in like
social work class criminal justice at 8
a.m. like yeah dad Ashley yeah sorry my
teacher for that but III I had to like I
had to get some rest
what is that I mean I know that we
talked about Texas all the time what is
it gonna take everybody jerks for them
to be back it can they be I mean there
was that we were back then what happened
what recruiting class were you at Texas
I was there with you
uh Alex Oh Cooper Mason Walters Garrett
you came over
yeah it's my boy I ain't going over that
one gang a lot oh so this is why Texas
didn't continue winning we told Robert
Griffin he was a receiver he won the
Heisman get Johnny Manziel told him he
wasn't safety he was a safety baker
Millfield Mayfield was in our backyard
JT Barrett was in Houston who was it was
a quarterback Oregon just a Herbert oh
you know back when I was there um Davis
something was Davis Webb no before that
it was Cal I know who you talking about
I kid anyways Andrew Luck was in Houston
and strapped for I think sharp or high
school Matt Stafford well a lot of
people say Mack Brown five Heisman
winner and he stopped looking
he stopped doing the research what was I
think you know we invested all our
resources in one player this guy's gonna
be I mean cuz garre's Gary Player of the
Year and you know had an awesome high
school career at Lake Travis my kids got
Lake Charles now by the way and you know
we I think I think sometimes you got to
work you got to treat each recruiting
class
you can't promise oh we're not gonna
recruit anybody out right we got to
rebuild like I thought about pumping
this yeah keeping this train going so
when you when you met when five Heisman
quarterbacks come out of text and they
don't go to you
texture Texas that's why we're at where
you might not right no I think you are
right and we'll see if Sam can get it
done this year missing some people like
there's more Pat maja Pat was in Texas
hi yeah that's a big that's a big one
yeah yeah I did ask him once like why
didn't you go to Texas and he's dead
laboratory so he said he said I was in a
camp in high school and I went and I've
had so many of my friends tell me I may
not want to go take you so bad they did
offer me cuz cuz you don't have to
recruit outside the state so a lot of my
teammates that are from like outside the
state they're like man that was
factorial of 1 he's like I wanted to go
to Texas if they'd all be out it went
immediately things that could have been
for you guys right now we'll be back
yeah yeah we'll be fine
we beat the [ __ ] sorry yeah there's good
we've killed Georgia like like in the
Sugar Bowl that was a big win there and
I thought they were better than Alabama
left that year in Utah this year was a
big win as well he's got to be
consistent we got to consistently beat
the team that we're supposed to be even
when I was there I mean I don't even
know like it was just a lot of luth like
this is all losing you know I'm saying
you don't matter didn't matter what I
did I don't care that I was an
all-american or a personal Drive pit
because my you know my legacy at Texas
we didn't you got to win championships
like that's the only thing that really
matters so that's why I like when we
made this run this year I didn't care
about the Pro Bowl or All Pro or
whatever the fact that we made like
Tennessee like those those fans they're
gonna be in the stadium makes you're
going to ACC championship it doesn't
matter how many Pro Bowlers you have or
that's just a joke anyway I'll probably
know that yeah it's insane
yeah I'm sorry NFL that's right Logan
Roger to me the Pro Bowl hit 120 tackles
5 sacks 5 pick as a corner with Xavier
Rhodes made who is it Deon didn't know
I'm fired was I'll argue like who
shouldn't made it at the same time we
all work hard we all wake up every day
and we want to grind and make I'm just
saying I just know who should have made
it yep I'm not even saying myself I'm
saying my teammates like I was there
every day if I like me K being looking
every day 5:30 a.m.
BAM but we're not posting on Instagram
for everybody yeah that's all it is
Kenny worked out alright ma'am we gotta
close our show get these people out here
thank you for coming by
you know you're my man's been a while
that's been we supposed to wake up
I shouldn't went to the Senior Bowl I
know so Kenny is actually gonna take my
job when he retires it's a it's a secret
it's crazy because I don't watch as much
film as I used like I used to like know
like what guys are coming out and I the
further along getting to lead unless you
do it but um but I still read all the
articles there we go
biggest fan right here right thanks for
stopping by man that's our show live
from the be our gridiron house check it
out Wednesday morning we'll be back in
studio at home getting you ready for the
NFL Scouting Combine it's the end of
February